great person we concede you know what we
had a go at this it was horrendous we've
had to rain it all back we're going to
do the honorable thing we're going to
let somebody else have a go I would
rather we try somebody who at least is
economically numerate someone who bait
has a basic understanding of the economy
and Nadeem I've got great respect for
you you always used to come on Good
Morning Britain when a lot of your
colleagues wouldn't and I'd Bellow away
at you and you just take it and you're
great and you were great on vaccines but
for you honestly to sit there and try
and defend this what I haven't heard
from anybody at senior level in this
party in the last 10 days is one word
sorry sorry to the country for what you
have put the country through you want to
say it so peers you said you said that
word you said no I'm going to tell you
I'm going to tell you Liz said I've
listened and I get it which is why 95 of
her Economic Policy of her growth plan
she wanted to protect and will deliver
right the stuff we've just talked about
but are you sorry it's been done and and
the five percent that was damaging yeah
she cut and as Wilfred said you cut and
you move forward you've got 24 most of
them
right now if you give me a chance sure
well ask yourself this question what
would blood Vladimir Putin want us to do
he wants to be divided right now because
he's using energy oh come on come on
you can't say sorry
do you not believe that Vladimir Putin
is using energy which is where the
inflation is coming from where countries
around the world are having to raise
interest rate with respect what does
this have to do with a simple apology to
them
for the train wreck that has happened in
the last 10 days I said to you Liz in
her conference he said I get it and I
and I I'm sorry I changed the policy I'm
sorry of course I'm sorry thank you
thank you by the way there's nothing
wrong with saying I get it and I've
listened and I've acted and 95 what I
want to do I'm going to deliver and I'll
drop the five percent that's a good
thing but for you to say that Putin has
nothing to do with inflation is I didn't
say that no he didn't say that I didn't
say that yeah
okay so if you think he had something to
do with inflation then as did with
in the last 10 days so far for the for
the Monumental cock-up you did with this
mini budget I've so far heard people
blame the queen and the funeral or what
happened you're now blaming Vladimir
Putin and I'm saying to you actually
it's simpler than that your mini budget
calls the kid okay okay tell you what
Vladimir Putin is using energy
of course okay and countries around the
world bankers are having to increase
your points you're both major points